continuons à manger du poisson c'est le
message lancé par didier guillaume le
ministre de l'agriculture le 7 avril
dernier un problème en france la pêche
est quasiment à l'arrêt impossible de
reprendre l'activité avec les mesures
sanitaires
les pêcheurs subissent des pertes
économiques catastrophiques malgré les
aides européennes envisagée illustration
à cherbourg avec solène gaudin cynthia
lauvergeon et morgane france en quatre
chalutiers à quai depuis bientôt six
semaines
du jamais vu pour david leroy marin
pêcheur depuis 30 ans et plus gros
armateur du coton temps est rentré de 17
ans président a dit qu'il fallait
confiné on a fait rentrer nos quatre
bateaux plus d'un mois comme ça c'est
une première on nous ment on veut c'est
de retourner à la mère alpiq voilà que
combat de bâton travail qui a dit
rentrées d'argent que les grands un
salaire comme on était avant reprendre
la mer impensable tant que les gestes
barrières sont de rigueur à bord d'un
bateau de pêche la proximité entre les
marins est inévitable ils sont à quatre
dans un mètre carré grosso modo la
manutention les cov ça se fait toujours
à deux dans la cale c'est pareil ils
sont à deux ils sont toujours côte des
uns des autres par l'interphone seuls
les gaullistes des pêches pour remonter
veut remettre leur gréement
alors on va pas dire avant un temps je
me dis massicotte parce qu'on n'est pas
un maître la vase y passer jeu passera
après ses forces et c'est pas possible
autre impact de l'épidémie des revenus
qui plonge depuis le début du
confinement cet armateur perd cinq cent
mille euros de chiffre d'affaires par
mois pour sortir la tête de l'eau
l'union européenne a accordé aux
professionnels du secteur une aide
financière
mais cette indemnité sera versée
seulement à l'horizon 2021
en attendant seul moyen de ne pas couler
redémarrer avec en ligne de mire le 11
mai une reprise néanmoins conditionnée
par l'activité de ses clients
voilà toute façon pas tout simplement
que les restaurants sont fermés les
cantines les collectivités tout seul
tout est fermé pour nous
on va prendre notre poisson c'est sûr et
certain non si c'est pour la lame est
rapide et enfin de compte va confronter
picdi en a fait une mauvaise vente les
gorges va vous donner comme nous on est
payé à la part on n a pas de fixe les
gore ils vont faire un enfer la tête en
france 16 mille pêcheurs professionnels
sont concernés tous navigue à vue en
attendant une reprise générale